now a father whose three children were
killed by his mentally ill wife has told
sky news that the mental health care
system in ireland needs serious reform
andrew mcginley's wife deidre was found
not guilty of the children's murder by
reason of insanity
mr mcginley who's now taking legal
action has been speaking to our island
correspondent stephen murphy and a
warning you may find the details in his
report distressing
this is the last video andrew mckinley
has of his children
six days after this was recorded all
three were dead
two years ago today nine-year-old connor
seven-year-old dara and three-year-old
carla were suffocated at the family home
in newcastle county dublin by their
mother deirdre morley she was later
found not guilty of murder by reason of
insanity andrew remembers returning home
from work as the first responders
arrived it was then that i
thought where are the children
so um
i discovered their their bodies in the
house uh when i when i went in
and um
but um you
you you just think it doesn't happen
how does this happen to you to you you
just look for answers and two years
later i'm still looking for answers
after the trial andrew's wife was
committed to a mental hospital in dublin
have you forgiven her
i can't forgive how the the the children
died i understand that she was ill
i mean the the director that i knew and
loved was a loving and caring mother she
was a nurse deirdre morley had been
receiving psychiatric care before the
deaths but andrew now wants legislative
reform so that families of those who are
mentally ill can be included in their
treatment it's just
led me with so many more questions
and i think if i was included all the
way along then i wouldn't have those
questions or i'd already know the
answers
two years on andrew has honored connor's
wish for a youtube channel by creating
connor's clips
sharing videos from happier times
i tried to think if i hadn't
if i didn't have conor's clips
what would i do
because that
every morning the alarm goes off it hits
you like a sledgehammer what has
happened
the videos show the close bond between
the boys and their sister carla
you should have a little fairy costume
on their wand cause you have to wave
your wand she goes in going on changing
you into monkeys and frogs and the two
lads are yeah yeah work away changes and
they start jumping around the place
you've turned them both into frogs
and for me that was the bomb between
them oh my goodness will you turn them
back into boys andrew has also started a
colouring competition for carla and a
charity in dara's name he says these
legacy projects keep him going day to
day
is to remember conor darinkar
that's why you're doing this yeah
yeah
to keep the promises
night stephen murphy sky news in dublin